nous avons livré des armes et aider
économiquement et sur le plan
humanitaire l'Ukraine pour résister nous
avons livré depuis le début de la guerre
vous savez plusieurs plusieurs
équipements des équipements du carburant
des véhicules blindés beaucoup de
missiles pour se protéger et ces fameux
canon César ce qu'on fait en même temps
et ce qu'on va livrer ça ça ne dépend de
personne d'autre que de nous ce sont des
radars des systèmes et des missiles pour
les protéger justement de ces attaques
en particulier pour les protéger des
attaques de drone et des attaques
domicile avez-vous pensé des
déclarations d'Emmanuel Macron vous êtes
d'accord avec lui il faut continuer à
armer l'Ukraine pour cette partie oui
oui après il y a toujours il y a
toujours des des chaussures à redire on
lui a reproché son intervention par
rapport au nucléaire parce que certains
ont pensé que il a la trop dit d'autres
ont pensé qu'il a pas assez dit voilà
donc mais est-ce que c'est le devoir de
la France de livrer des armes aux
Ukrainiens non c'est pas un devoir
non j'ai un choix un choix est-ce que
c'est un bon choix pour moi oui pour moi
oui pour vous Bertrand c'est un mauvais
choix alors déjà juste pour revenir moi
je pense qu'il parle trop et il écoute
pas assez notre président donc il dit
oui c'est notre président et on a le
droit de dire que quelqu'un parle
beaucoup on a le droit de le dire et
vous dites vous-même il parle énormément
sans arrêt il est tout le temps dans les
médias et manifestation
il écoute peu parce qu'en fait on a un
certain nombre de parties qui sont
impliqués dans ce conflit et le
président russe également parle
régulièrement il explique en fait sa
position et on a manifestement en face
de lui des gens qui n'écoutent pas donc
au début il avançait d'une certaine
manière dans sa campagne en Ukraine et
puis il a été chatouillé un peu en hors
string puis le pont de KERS en Crimée et
il a décidé de s'énerver et au lieu de
tous se mettre autour de la table et
dire ok on a compris
finalement vous êtes loin d'être
affaibli vous n'êtes pas aussi malade
vous n'êtes pas aussi caché puisqu'il
continue à voyager partout dans le monde
etc enfin que des mensonges
au lieu de ça on annonce hyper vite en
fait quasiment dans la minute on va
continuer à armer donc on dit la France
est en guerre d'une certaine manière
puisqu'elle fournit des armes à
belligérant des armes lourdes maintenant
des armes entièresiennes qui sont by the
way celles qui font le plus de dégâts en
ce moment dans les grandes villes
ukrainiennes c'est ces armes qui ratent
leur cible et qui puisque tout ça ça a
été vous pensez que ça peut ça peut ça
en venime la situation dans venime la
situation vous savez quand tu es un pays
comme la France qui est censé être un
pays qui aide qui calme les choses et
qui permet aux acteurs de discuter
c'était notre position historique est un
pays qui est un des belligérants en
apportant des armes déjà on est
décrédibilisé pour parler de thé vous
pouvez pas parler de thé quand vous êtes
déjà dans un camp vous êtes décrit
débilisés mais auprès de l'interlocuteur
dont vous aimeriez qu'il fasse la paix
il a beaucoup écouté il a passé
énormément de temps au téléphone avec
Macron jusqu'au jour où il a compris que
ça servait à rien et effectivement à
partir de là mais parce qu'en fait il
avait un interlocuteur avec lequel il
avait un certain type d'échange et dès
que le président faisait un feedback à
la population française il disait autre
chose que ce qui avait été échangé et
les Russes revenaient en disant non
c'est pas du tout ce qu'on a dit donc
chacun faisait un compte rendu qui était
opposé donc à un moment vous quand vous
parlez avec quelqu'un et que vous avez
une certaine conversation et consiste la
personne c'est un résumé et qui est
différente ce que vous avez dit vous
dites
aux Français qui disent il faut arrêter
d'armée l'Ukraine
mais moi je pense qu'il faut
effectivement arrêter d'armer l'Ukraine
parce qu'il est temps de faire la paix
et d'arrêter ce conflit vous savez avant
de conflit en Ukraine il y avait des
accords de Minsk dans la France était
garant l'Allemagne était également
garant de ses accords et on n'a pas aidé
à respecter ces accords on a continué à
aider à financer les accords malgré le
non respect des accords c'est quoi les
accords de mixte les accords de
Minecraft c'était de dire que petit un
les les
combats allez s'arrêter en fait au
niveau du d'en bas les Russes qui ont
commencé ces combats ils vont rester sur
les territoires qu'ils ont occupé
on veut juste parler une petite question
qui a attaqué le crâne le 24 février
c'est l'Ukraine ou c'est la Russie mais
c'est l'Ukraine ou c'est la Russie
monsieur c'est le frère de la Russie et
je vais vous donner un autre exemple
et c'est le répond vous vous rappelez
Zidane il a donné un coup de boule à
d'accord vous rappelez et finalement il
a eu un carton haut je mets tout le
monde a trouvé que c'était génial il
avait été provoqué provoqué provoquer et
on en a fait un duo et il est resté
parce que le marketing a décidé que le
coup de boule de Zidane c'était pas mal
alors que quand les États-Unis attaquent
les États-Unis et l'OTAN attaquent la
Yougoslavie là le marketing dit c'est
génial il faut bombarder il fallait
rayer le temps avec la vous avez vu les
différences d'images entre Bagdad
puisqu'on était tous devant nos télé à
regarder
quelle est la raison avec l'Ukraine
Poutine a attaqué l'Ukraine point barre
et ne cherchez pas ne cherchez pas les
excuses ma Poutine vous avez eu hier le
vote on a choisi notre
état qui ont soutenu
il y a quatre étapes
qui ont soutenu le Poutine Corée du Nord
il y a de Russie Nicaragua et la série
du côté et la Russie non non non
et qui correspondent à plus de la moitié
de l'humanité et s'abstenir quand il y a
les pressions diplomatiques qui sont
chacun de ces pays-là sur les chiffres
il y en a plein qui se sont abstenus
aussi il y a 25 États oui c'est vrai que
ce soit absolu donc c'est c'est quand
même 35 35 ouais donc c'est quand même
énorme voilà juste aujourd'hui
est-ce que la France prend un risque en
continuant d'armer l'Ukraine est-ce
qu'on voit de plus en plus de français
dans les rues je vous le dis le français
qui me parle il me disent attention nous
ça commence à nous gonfler je dis je me
fais le porte-parole de ce que je vois
sur les réseaux de porte-parole de ce
que mes viennent me dire les Français
quand je les croise dans la rue parce
que vous connaissez très bien le
problème mais là je parle des Français
les Français qui disent tous les jours
qui n'ont pas d'essence actuellement
qui sont dans une galère monstre qui
voit l'hiver arriver et qui se disent on
est on devait déjà être dans la merde
est-ce qu'on va pas être encore plus
dans la merde et qui se pose beaucoup de
questions donc là la question elle est
là on a vu le président à préciser la
dernière fois il a bien fait de le faire
de dire l'essence ça n'a rien à voir
avec l'Ukraine ouais il a bien fait de
le faire parce qu'il y a plein de gens
au départ qui disent c'est la guerre en
Ukraine qui faisait qu'on avait pas
descendre donc il a bien fait de le
préciser le président le président parce
qu'on savait plus mais c'est vrai que
voilà est-ce que ça peut nous retomber
dessus on n'est pas français qui se
disent est-ce que ça va nous retomber
dessus elle est vraiment pour résumer tu
entends les mêmes choses que moi non
seulement je l'entends mais moi je le
pense j'ai fait comme tout le monde au
mois de mars allez souvent l'Ukraine il
y a pas de problème avril mais finit
l'abondance ok on a foi avec l'Ukraine
mais combien de temps elle va durer
cette guerre parce que ok la pénurie
c'est pas c'est pas l'Ukraine mais les
deux euro 10 c'est l'Ukraine et nous
avons dit non c'est assez le prix de
l'essence qu'augmenter il faut
m'expliquer comment c'est parti de de
connaissance 65 % c'est les taxes déjà
ça n'a rien à voir si vous faites 65% du
prix ce sont des taxes avant le prêt le
prix du le prix de pas rentrer là-dedans
dans les années 2000 c'est le pétrole il
était à 100 dollars on payait on payait
le gasoil en euro 30 arrêtez il y avait
quand même 60 % de taxes il y a les pays
de l'OPE qui se sont réunis il y a une
semaine que vous décidez d'arrêter la
production de de 1 million par jour de
baril c'est-à-dire que de d'augmenter
artificiellement le prix de pétrole vous
êtes bien armé l'Ukraine pour venir
à un moment donné à un moment donné vous
avez entendu vous avez entendu ce que ça
on veut pas payer l'électricité plus
cher on peut pas payer d'essence plus
cher on veut pas mais c'est nous dire
qu'il faut mettre le chauffage à 17 à 18
à 19 on veut rester libre on veut aussi
que ça chez nous faut assumer nous dire
le quoi qu'il en coûte machin on veut
bien nous aider mais ça va durer ça va
durer combien de temps vous êtes prêts
non mais je vous explique j'essaie de
vous expliquer je sais de vous expliquer
il y a les pays de producteur producteur
de pétrole ils ont décidé d'Ar d'arrêter
de produire un million de barils par
jour à cause de ça le prix de pétrole a
augmenté ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'Ukraine non mais alors en plus
il était à 140 dollars s'il vous plaît
en quoi l'Ukraine la guerre en Ukraine
touche les Français c'est ce que je veux
savoir mais ça touche les Français parce
qu'en fait en février la France l'Union
européenne un certain nombre de pays ont
décidé de mettre en place des sanctions
qui nous touchent nous bien plus que les
Russes c'est à dire au début des
sanctions étaient censées mettre si vous
vous rappelez les phrases mettre la
Russie à genoux etc la Russie
aller supplier l'ensemble des pays du
monde
d'accepter en fait une reddition
complète c'est pas du tout ce qui se
passe après six mois tous les chiffres
économiques sa sortie les chiffres
concrètement
c'est simple en quoi concrètement les
Français
en fait on avait des contrats qui nous
permettaient d'avoir du gaz à batterie
et encore 40% de l'énergie en Allemagne
c'est du gaz et le fait de rompre ces
contrats multiplier le prix du gaz par
15 ans c'est à dire que maintenant on
achète le gaz au prix spot à domicile
mais vous n'y connaissez rien alors
taisez-vous monsieur puis moi
j'ai un diplôme d'économie sur Internet
vous n'avez rien du tout et donc et donc
déjà nous vous me dites pas de me taire
vous ne connaissez rien du tout porte
vous êtes une grande gueule et vous
connaissez absolument aucun chiffre
est-ce que vous savez que la Russie la
banque centrale actuellement perd 17
milliards par mois de réserver de
réserve et le crédit la Russie et c'est
la Russie
la France la France
Ukraine parce qu'elle subit bien
évidemment un certain nombre de
conséquences des marchés internationaux
mais pour le gaz pour le gaz le virus
représente dans la balance énergétique
française 2,72%
. j'ai un sac moi j'ai toujours le même
sac hein dedans il y avait l'ancien
ticket caisse ouais c'est mes cours je
fais le même parcours je rentre d'abord
je prends les décès les petits déjeuners
après j'avance je prends les les
surgelés jouer au fromage je regarderai
après mon premier point d'interrogation
avec moins de trucs
on a eu trois années de
covidence
vous avez là vous avez voilà vous avez
la conjonction internationale bien
évidemment l'Ukraine et ça ça peut agir
ça peut ajouter ça peut ajouter mais
c'est pas c'est pas ça la base c'est pas
ça alors c'est quoi juju en quoi les
Français sont touchés
vous vous parlez de morale mais sur le
plan économique il y a des vrais
conséquences prenons le blé et ma maman
on peut pas tout avoir absolument voilà
mais quand on parle de blé par exemple
le prix du blé ça rejailli sur les prix
de matière première dont les Français la
France la France
la France c'est le 4e producteur de blé
dans le monde non mais donc
la France
vous avez des idées et là vous voulez
même pas particulièrement bien éduqué
justement vous savez comment on fait du
blé on met des graines et ensuite il
faut des engrais et vous savez comment
on fait les engrais avec du gaz avec du
gaz russe 80% mais pas du gaz russe mais
si mais il y a plein de pays qui
produisent de gaz alors lesquels
donnez-moi la liste vous vous connaissez
moi la liste oui bien sûr alors allez-y
je vous pose la question vous connaissez
le premier fournisseur de gaz de Chine
pardon vous connaissez qui le premier
fournisseur pour la Chine de gaz
l'Indonésie non
Australie non 40%, 40 % des mecs
monsieur le gaz mais vous êtes ridicule
le regardez c'est l'Australie à la Chine
mais l'Australie ne produit pas de gaz
produit
la vraie question voilà qu'on se pose ce
soit puisqu'on a vu que le président a
dit que on allait continuer d'armer
l'Ukraine juste la question que je vous
pose à tous les deux pour vraiment
aussi sur le débat et avoir des réponses
claires avant qu'on passe à la pénurie
de carburant qu'est-ce que ça peut avoir
comme impact sur la France et est-ce
qu'on peut être touché par des attaques
russes ou rentrer en guerre contre la
Russie non non pourquoi non parce que
parce que il est les Russes l'ont montré
ils sont extrêmement patients il leur a
fallu 6 mois pour
patients ils ont perdu la guerre déjà
mais va regarder l'armée russe et porte
quoi mais c'est pas possible
l'armée qui est considéré dans les pays
complètement faible vous regardez bien
en place
mais il raconte n'importe quoi alors
dites-nous
dites nous en quoi en quoi on peut être
alors on sera pas touché militairement
non on est touché militairement parce
qu'on est des armées aujourd'hui c'est à
dire qu'on donne l'essentiel de nos
armes où c'est pour fournir les armes en
ce moment à l'Ukraine les commandes par
exemple du Danemark pour fournir
c'est-à-dire que le rythme de psy
de production en fait
et pas suffisante en fait pour
renouveler les âmes qu'on donne à
l'Ukraine donc on est obligé de prendre
sur d'autres fronts on a quand même une
armée professionnelle qui est uniquement
professionnelle on n'a pas d'armée donc
imaginons qu'on doit mobiliser en quoi
on doit être contre de continuer d'armée
l'Ukraine pourquoi mais parce que ça ne
sert absolument à rien ça en venime une
situation pour vous c'est déjà compliqué
vous savez aujourd'hui on a des
problèmes avec le gaz avec l'électricité
pour l'hiver les fameux col roulés etc
dans six mois le problème ça va être le
pain parce que
les gens vont avoir 100 et qu'est-ce qui
va se passer dans six mois on va dire
bah écoutez vous avez faim mais allez
travailler il faut continuer en fait
c'est ridicule comme situation il faut
en arrêter avec cette guerre
ça c'est vrai Sergueï c'est le blé c'est
les matières premières qui vont manquer
on voit que tout augmente et tout est
mais oui mais serviette le papier tout
c'est bien l'Australie le premier
fournisseur de gaz en Chine
40 % la vérité donc sur les maisons
alors bien sûr autre chose quels sont
les quels sont quels vont être les
conséquences pour la France est-ce qu'on
se demande tous et c'est ce que je
demande les Français parce que ils se
disent à chaque fois on a un moment je
vous dis à bientôt problème en France
les Français disent ça cause la guerre
en Ukraine non c'est pourquoi la guerre
en Ukraine impacte sur le continent des
Français c'est quasiment rien quasiment
rien je suis d'accord avec vous mais
littéralement la France ne risque rien
du tout vous avez raison par rapport à
ça mais je suis d'accord avec vous pour
augmenter ou pas mais c'est mais c'est
pas mais c'est pas par rapport la France
produit le blé c'est la France est à le
quatrième exploitateur de blé plus qu'il
ne faut pour le blé le prix des pâtes
qui explose ça c'est l'alimentation
l'antidienne Sergueï mais vous pouvez
pas le nier mais c'est la guerre il faut
il faut pas tout mettre sur la graine de
les crêpes parce que Monsieur dit que
tout ce qui se passe mal en France c'est
à cause de la graine de c'est à cause de
la guerre en Ukraine et donc il faut
arrêter de se soutenir l'Ukraine et
comme ça ça irait très très bien vous
verrez bien que c'est la France arrête
de se tenir le frêne tout ira aussi mal
que on peut mettre non non pas ça mais
ça impacte la vie quotidienne non alors
non Gilles on aurait ça impacte la vie
quotidienne mais ça impacte parce que le
prix des matières premières c'est dans
votre tête c'est pas dans ma tête
est-ce que vous m'écoutez c'est la
guerre ce n'est pas la guerre de
l'Ukraine parce que il y a ce qu'on
appelle la conjoncture internationale ça
impacte toujours il y a autre chose il y
a les marchés il y a les producteurs il
y a le prix de de matières premières
mais c'est pas parce que la guerre en
Ukraine appart tout non ça c'est faux
l'Ukraine grenier de l'Europe c'est une
réalité ça c'est la France la France
produit autant que l'Ukraine
on va voir ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs tiens euh la France
doit-elle continuer non à 76 %, la
France doit-elle continuer d'armée
Ukraine non à 76 %, c'est un choix
incroyable
je voudrais avoir vraiment je voulais
avoir Sergueï et Bertrand ce soir c'est
fou c'est aussi quand même je suis pas
être oui mais rassurez-vous en fait le
truc c'est que j'aurais voulu vous dire
dès le début vous savez combien la
France a dépensé pour armer le prêt
2900 260 millions vous savez combien les
États-Unis ont dépensé pouvoir mais
l'Ukraine 15 milliards mais alors vous
comprenez la différence
donc vous vous me dites que avec 260
millions que la France a donné pour
armer l'Ukraine la France va très très
mal parce que vous avez votre producteur
et votre PIB qui a chuté c'est n'importe
quoi les États-Unis ont donné 15
milliards l'Angleterre a donné 4
milliards vous comprenez la différence 4
milliards et 260 milliards
comprenez que la preuve ça donnait rien
du tout elle a donné 18 César et il est
en train actuellement de donner encore
si César et Monsieur dit la France c'est
désarmé la France possédait 72 César et
la donnée quoi et la donner un tiers qui
sait qui va vous attaquer l'Espagne la
Suisse la Belgique
vous avez besoin pourquoi vous avez
besoin de ça en France
en Italie la Suisse juste Daniel tu as
vu le tu t'entendu dire c'était pas
étonné en tout cas c'est moi c'est ce
que je pense j'ai peur je trouve que ça
ne sert à rien on nous parle de l'Europe
de l'OTAN et tout ça moi je serai
d'accord pour que une grande puissance
je vous souhaite mais nous avec nos
petits bras c'est pour nous
et là c'est le mot clé
vous avez peur c'est ça je pense que
beaucoup de gens la peur n'est pas
rationnel c'est ça le problème la peur
les gens ont peur et donc ils ont peur
de cette guerre et ils disent c'est à
cause de l'Ukraine et donc faisons la
paix mais moi j'ai peur parce que si on
c'est pas l'Ukraine bien sûr le
contraire on disait exactement la même
chose en 1938 99
cet exemple qui est nul je te le dis
arrêtez chaque fois quelqu'un il dit
dans le même exemple il est nul à chier
mais merci c'est un exemple mais sinon
c'est un exemple ça n'a rien à voir
allez merci d'Autriche ça vous dit rien
par rapport à l'annexion de la clé mais
pas 2000 j'espère que vous voyez le
sondage vous dites quoi les sud-êtes ça
ne vous dit rien par rapport
parce qu'en fait les gens petit à petit
en fait après 6 mois il s'intéresse il
regarde sur internet ils écoutent ils
entendent les différentes déclarations
se disent c'est moins simple ce qu'on
m'a raconté au début les choses sont
beaucoup plus complexes c'est c'est pas
il a attaqué il est méchant etc il est
méchant il est attaqué
mais oui mais vous aviez expliqué qu'il
allait mourir donc vous aviez expliqué
tellement de choses si vous la verrez
au niveau international j'ai parlé de
mit qui a régné pendant 15 ans avec les
cancers
tout le monde loue la position de
d'Emmanuel Macron Président
on verra ce qu'il en est dans quelque
temps merci à vous deux d'avoir été la
soirée merci